hey this city is filled with terrific
women who are making decisions
choices and career moves that are very
impressive
since this is international women's day
to commemorate cultural political and
social economic achievements of women
kevin martin found a young woman who
works with the aces who fits that mold
some days when i think about this job i
really think that it's passion and
purpose
coming together for me christine monger
is making it happen
in both the sports and business worlds i
always knew i wanted to be in business
and i knew that i wanted to
support women but i didn't really know
that i was going to do those at the same
time
fast forward to 2017 and she's doing
just that
right here in las vegas today holding
the title of vp of business operations
for the city's lone women's professional
team i always tell people i fell in love
with women's basketball in 2017 and i've
just never looked back
and really the organization as a whole
hasn't looked back either
to go from a space where people would
say you know what sport is the aces
to you make it to the finals in your
third season
it's been i mean absolutely incredible
and it's near impossible not to cheer
for a group of strong
powerful women who are the most elite at
what they do
to know this team is to love them i mean
how do you not love asia wilson
and kelsey plum and this campaign you
know they're incredible athletes and
they're incredible women
the future sure is bright here in the
sunny desert for this
group of women especially with their new
enthusiastic
team owner mark davis talk about walking
the walk
you know the way he talks about the
women the way he wants to make sure
they have what they need it's just
really inspiring kevin martin 8 sports
now